I'm only prepared to receive these
migrants that are coming or that are
expected to come this year compared to
other countries with rich country with
high living conditions so I think it's
our obligation to help these help these
people if you look to the situation in
Syria it's obvious under which
conditions these people had to leave
their country so this is our first
obligation on the other side it's also
clear that other member states of the
European have to take their part of the
shear so we have to do two things first
of all help the people here make sure
that they can work as soon as possible
make sure that they learn German as soon
as possible and on the other side it's
also clear we have to talk to our
European friends this is a European goal
that we all have to put our part into it
but do you think a European solution is
at all possible when you consider that
different countries have very different
interests in all this it's good that the
Chancellor finally spoke out towards
that direction and made clear that this
is a European challenge for all of us
but there's a lot to do I mean just to
give you two examples cosa was still not
recognized as an independent state by
five member states of the European Union
look at Macedonia Greece still refuses
to recognize the name of that country so
how can you have stability in a region
wherein one member state does not
recognize the name of the other state
and where five member states do not
recognize one independent state there so
that doesn't help to have an investment
friendly climate to have growth jobs in
those countries and of course we also
have to put pressure on those countries
I mean I decided in the German Bundestag
about laws in in Greece and the members
of the Parliament in Greece just have to
follow what was decided in other
Parliament's so if we can put that kind
of pressure to Greece why can't we talk
to those countries and at the same time
make clear you have to fight against
corruption you have to make sure that
your citizens have better living
conditions in particular the Roma
citizens have living conditions that fit
to a country that wants to join the
European Union in the last few hours
we've seen a lot of migrants trying to
come to Germany from Hungary how big a
problem is this for Germany
I mean it shows one thing if you have to
leave your country because of war
because bombs explode next to you and
you want to save the life of your
children no walls can stop you so
instead of investing money into walls we
should welcome these people and benefit
from them that makes much more sense in
my opinion and of course on the other
side we also have to look into the
causes the root causes why these people
leave their country and in the case of
Syria it's obviously not easy but we
have to make sure that together with
Russia together with Iran we come to a
solution that we had an interim
government for for Syria in order to
stop that war and then fight together
against Isis thanks a lot mr. Jose
Malcolm